hi I'm Erik Bosse and spider-man into
the spider-verse is a new trailer that
takes us even deeper into the animated
crossover movie following a whole bunch
of spider people just in case the venom
movie leaves a bad taste in your mouth
here's a fistful of red and blue pills
don't wash it out this trailer
definitely makes me feel like I'm on
some kind of wonderful drug so let's run
through all these shots frame by frame
for the details references and easter
eggs that you might have miss spoiler
warning in case any my predictions are
too right and let's get started my name
is Peter Parker I'm pretty sure you know
the rest
I sake the city fell in love then I
saved the city again and again and again
look I'm a comic book serial you get a
Christmas album and it's so-so popsicle
okay this first section introduces us to
the Peter Parker we're familiar with
specifically the Tobey Maguire version
from the Sam Raimi movies notice how
these opening shots all depict moments
from those movies the train stopped from
spider-man to the kiss from the first
movie and the car crashed into the cafe
from spider-man 2 remember that when Doc
Ock thought it'd be a good idea to tell
Peter Parker to deliver a message to
spider-man after throwing a car at him
this spider-man is voiced by Jake
Johnson he's looking like the spider-man
from the normal earth-616 or maybe with
these Raimi references a different
spider-man related to that Raimi
universe then we see more vignettes of
spider-man's past heroics and I just
love the animation style that we've been
seeing in these trailers director
producers Phil Lord and Chris Miller one
of this movie's to feel like a living
painting like you walked into a comic
book apparently this movie has used the
largest staff of animators ever for the
studio and you could see that attention
to detail with these printer dots kind
of like the ones you'd see if you look
closely at the pages of a comic book as
well as these impact lines to convey
action and movement even though those
aren't really needed for an animated
feature and little detail here I like
how those images are depicted like a
comic book with webbing forming the
frame of the lines and of course many of
these scenes show spider-man villains
he's fighting scorpion there and
upper-left well as Doc Ock and the
lizard the comic book Peter mentions is
a real life spider-man cover the amazing
spider-man issue 186 though they changed
the title to true like tales this Spidey
O's cereal could be a nod to the
spider-man cereal from the 90s that
promoted the spider-man animated series
and this melted gooey Spiderman popsicle
was actually a picture taken of a
real-life popsicle from the film staff
and the
it's Christmas album are all great
fighty it's cold outside swinging around
the mistletoe
silent night you're welcome joy to the
world that I just saved by deed a
snowman
it's beginning to look like a
non-denominational holiday and Ave Maria
I guess there's a no joke on that one
suppose it's just too beautiful moving
on but this isn't about me not anymore
spider-man swings in once a day zip zap
zop in his little mask and answers to no
one I love you morons dad I love you ok
here the trailer shifts from Peter
Parker's 6-1-6 earth to Miles Morales
enough 16:10 and you can see how the
coca-cola sign changes to coca soda in
the NYPD changes to PD and why the signs
on the cabs change as well mouths were
Alice is he spider-man in the Ultimate
Comics he actually takes over after
Peter Parker dies smiles his voice by
should make more he goes to this school
in Brooklyn and if you look closely you
could see the word Brooklyn on his
backpack that's another detail specific
to Miles Morales Peter Parker is a kid
from Queens Miles Morales patrols the
streets of Brooklyn let's move on my
name is Miles Morales I'm the one and
only spider-man at least that's what I
thought you'd be here for super collider
you're gonna love this
you're like me
that's impossible in this section we see
Marvel villain Wilson Fisk aka kingpin
voiced by Liam Schreiber who's actually
more giant-sized like he is in the
comics he appears to be operating some
kind of super collider probably modeled
on the real-life Large Hadron Collider
at CERN notice of the computer screens
display a fhc probe I'm guessing could
be alternate future Hadron Collider or
alternate frontier a trunk Collider this
glider appears to be opening some kind
of portal and causing different
spider-man universes to collide
notice how the particle beams take the
form of these ink dots that make up all
the other images almost as if the
colliders spilling the paint droplets of
one comic book issue into another very
cool detail on to the next clip right
kids listen up this part is your
universe saga it's weird it's gross and
this delicious normal fry is my universe
so you want to learn to be spider-man
key teacher yes I can hear mouths and
Peter meat and you can see one of those
red X alternate FedEx trucks parked
outside Peter explains the alternate
dimensions by using french fries as an
example which is actually the same way
that David Haller explained ultimate
realities and the marbled FX show Legion
the event that things we do just like a
million possible outcomes choices
choices in the Furious each outcome
actually happens look closely that
receipt those are all insane like thirty
thousand dollars for some burgers and
fries now this could be a joke about how
pricey food can sometimes be in New York
or maybe this universe takes place in a
reality where the value of the dollar
has depreciated and we start to see
Peter give miles some web-swinging
lessons except they don't really suit up
fully notice that Peter wears sweatpants
and Miles wears these Nike Air Jordan
ones moving on time to swing good double
tap to release and quit that out again
whip and release your natural lip
[Music]
hey guys who are you i'm gwen stacy okay
it's peter and miles swing through the
trees I like how Peter tells him to
double tap the web-shooter to release as
if it's a button on a video game
controller and he says flip as we see
the action word with appeared and we
meet Gwen Stacy aka spider-gwen she's
from Earth 65 a reality where she gets
bitten by a radioactive spider and Peter
Parker becomes the lizard
she's voiced by Hailee Steinfeld the
actress from bubble be notice time when
she glands she wears ballet slippers and
she lands one point woof not an easy way
to land especially on a tree branch
let's move on it can get weird okay
okay after we see Gwen drumming she
actually plays in a band called the Mary
Jane's in the comics we meet the rest of
the spider people first there's
spider-man noir from Earth 902 1-4 he
comes from a darker crime-ridden world
where he used his cons he actually kills
people he's voiced by Nicolas Cage and
he wears a fedora here though spider-man
noir doesn't normally have one of those
in comics next is penny Parker from
Earth one four five one two she gets
adopted by Uncle Ben and Aunt May and
she pilots the mek SP slash dear robot a
spider robot
she's voiced by Kimiko Glenn and notice
how the animation changes with her and
the comics Penny's aesthetic was more of
an homage to 90's seinen manga kind of
what Akira was but here she looks more
like the traditional Kappa Mikey style
sort of the aesthetic you see with
Sailor Moon and Hello Kitty her droid
lands in this sort of Peter Parker
Batcave or spider cave where you could
see what looks like a spider-man
skateboard and a black-and-white
portrait signed by somebody important to
me probably behind Peters Aunt May
voiced by Lily Tomlin and behind her
very interesting Easter Egg if you look
closely is the spider-man suit from the
recent insomniac PS sport game with a
white spider
logo then they made my favorite
spider-ham from Earth eighty-three
eleven he's Peter porker originally a
spider bitten by a radioactive pig that
turned him into a pig with the abilities
of a spider it's actually a running joke
that he gets annoyed with people who
call him spider pig since he's not to be
confused with the pig from The Simpsons
movement you peek
you Pig does whatever a spider Pig toys
and I love that his animation style is
unique as well unlike the others
spider-ham appears to be designed in a
style of Looney Tunes kind of like a
Porky Pig from Space Jam and he is
voiced by comedian John Mulaney and some
more details here before I move on Peter
Parker wears two different shoes because
apparently he's a hobo and the
background pictures of various villains
are webbed up you can see discs and
tombstone few others and the webs string
them together kind of like red yarn on a
police investigation board let's keep
going we need to get back to our
universes soon
Brooklyn is going to collapse my family
lives in Brooklyn
[Music]
it's here the various spider people are
in miles room where later on the wall
you can actually see a poster for chance
to rappers mixtape coloring book and
there's another shot of spider-gwen
landing once again on points and some
shots of Brooklyn and some kind of
interdimensional chaos
it looks like shards of different
colored animation pixels are
terraforming the buildings as though the
reality is being merged together is
actually destroying them then miles sits
with his uncle Aaron who's Aaron Davis
aka the Prowler whom we see chasing
miles with shoes that allow him to walk
on vertical surfaces he's voiced by
Maher Saleh Ali in the live-action MCU
donald clubber plays Aaron Davis and we
see other villains as well Fisk and then
scorpion and tombstone fighting miles
and spider-man noir and penny in the
house and we get a shot at this
character now this is Green Goblin I
know he appears a monster form that's
actually his appearance in the Ultimate
Comics moving on if I don't destroy the
collider none of us will have a home to
go home to remember what makes you
different this bowl is what makes you
spider-man
officer I love you wait
okay in this clip there's a shot of
miles in his room and I just love the
detail the Spider Man webbing hanging
from his bed notice this blue glow in
his hands that could be a nod to the
bioelectric energy that comes out of his
fingers in the comics though there it's
more of a yellow color and there's a lot
of quick cut action here with Miles
fighting Green Goblin and all leads to a
callback to this great I love you
exchange with his father so let's move
on to the final section do animals talk
in this dimension cuz I don't want to
freak him out okay after the titles we
get this great gag with the six spider
things clinging to the ceiling as miles
of school maid hangs out down below now
this could be gone Kaylie who is
basically turned into the Ned Leeds for
the spider-man homecoming movie whoever
this is the comic book he's reading is
and imagine that series which is a nod
to the what if Marvel Comics series
those were the ones that reimagine
interesting hypothetical events and
crossovers that otherwise wouldn't be
possible and check out the spider hand
here notice how as he scrambles to stay
with the group his legs scurry around in
that classic Looney Tunes scrambled
animation and the final shot of the
trailer is actually a book into the very
first shot with now miles slapping his
own brand on the same gargoyle statute
that we saw Peter sit on earlier and
actually his final pose on this statue
looks pretty familiar it's similar at
least to the black panther poster with
two chawla posing on his Wakanda Panther
which of these alternate spider people
and things are you most excited to see
comment down below with your thoughts
and follow me on Twitter and Instagram
at da boss subscribe to new rock stars
for all the deep dives into all the
stuff you love as long as it's not
sports or bachelor because you know we
are not cool and that's okay
[Music]